bonjour coindreau et dorado merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt france
alors on l'a dire l'espagne est
aujourd'hui le deuxième pays le plus
touché d'europe comment expliquer
justement la propagation rapide du virus
sur le sur le sol espagnol
il faut juste comprendre que le
président de la de gouvernement espagnol
a annoncé il y à peine 48 heures c'est
la semaine la plus difficile pour les
espagnols parce que normalement on sait
cette semaine dans quelques jours où on
attendra effectivement le pic de la du
cornât virus de cette pandémie
elle est allée très vite ces derniers
jours vous l'avez indiqué hier ça a été
24 heures le cauchemardesque puisque
l'espagne on a peine 24 heures à une 514
morts des plus et puis on est vraiment
sous la barre des quarante mille des
cadets positif au corona virus c'est une
situation très compliquée donc quelques
heures donc à peine 24 heures on
arrivera au 3000 morts en espagne
largement devant d'autres pays européens
et surtout et surtout sa touche vous
l'avez dit les personnes âgées mais
surtout ça touche aussi la région
démarré puisque plus de 50% des
personnes décédées l'ont été dans la
région de madrid
très vite difficile à expliquer mais ce
qui est certain c'est que auto en italie
au début de l'épidémie et l'été est
concentrée sur trois régions
essentiellement aujourd'hui c'est
pratiquement toute l'espagne qui est
touché par cette pâle délit mais sur 12
mais surtout la capitale madrid
le gouvernement va demander aujourd'hui
au parlement le prolongement des mesures
de confinement a décrété le 14 mars
dernier
comment les espagnols perçoivent les
mesures prises par les autorités
ils les perçoivent des façons positif si
on peut dire parce que on a bien compris
que la situation est extrêmement grave
et délicate donc le confinement se passe
beaucoup mieux qu'on ne pourrait le
croire quand il a été donc instauré
connaissant
la vie et quotidien des espagnols qui
passent beaucoup de temps
dès lors il voit avec ces chiffres que
nous avons annoncés effectivement des
prêts des 3000 décès et que le
confinement est obligatoire parce que
c'est un confinement plus un peu plus
dur qu'il ne l'est en france puisque
vous avez en espagne depuis le 14 mars
et il n'est pas non plus autorisé des
sortir faire du sport c'est c'est
complètement interdite en espagne en
confinement qui est difficile forcément
parce que les écoles sont aussi
logiquement fermée mais des façon
générale les espagnols comprennent que
c'est la main sur apprendre et parce que
il faut aussi quand même aider le
personnel sanitaire qui est très touché
par la pandémie vous savez que l'espagne
à un triste record
aujourd'hui c'est l'un des pays où le
personnel sanitaire les plus touchées
pratiquement 10 pers 10 % de personnel
sanitaire est contaminée par le coroner
virus et donc de ces espagnols savent
aussi qu'il faut laisser des et pour les
cd il faut rester chez soi croisé dorado
en ce moment en espagne
un débat a lieu autour notamment de
cette molécule de chloroquine qui fait
naître parfois une lueur d'espoir et
chez certains scientifiques chez
certains politiques mais aussi à travers
de la population est-ce que vous en
parlez vous en espagne de cette molécule
de deux chloroquine et comment ce
traitement est perçue effectivement on
en parle en espagne parce que tout le
monde est en attente de 2 de la remède
pour m peut-être pas fin à cette
pandémie en moi essayer de la contenir
surtout dans un pays où quand je vous
disais tout à l'heure à 40000 personnes
qui sont déjà testés positifs
on en parle beaucoup on a de l'espoir
parce qu'on a vu que d'autres pays comme
les etats unis ont beaucoup d'espoir
dans cette molécule même si en france sa
cause vraiment le débat mais l'espagne a
aussi pris aussi une autre décision
importante hausse est d essayer d
généraliser les tests pour savoir
quelles sont les personnes contaminées
depuis lundi
l'espagne a reçu 650 milles atteste au
coronavirus qui sont distribués dans les
hôpitaux et parmi la population
justement aussi pour savoir qui
sont malades et quelles sont les
personnes qui doivent être traitées
assez rapidement on sait que si on
traite si elle est décidée des scellés
la la contamination assez rapidement on
peut traiter les personnes et donc
l'espagne a aussi donc on attend dans
l'accord à qui nous à notre remède et
elle a décidé des métros en place quand
je vous dis c'est 650 mille tests c'est
un premier arrivage pour voir quelles
sont effectivement les personnes
contaminées
jusqu'aujourd'hui faut le rappeler on
est déjà à quarante mille au rythme
actuel des prix entre 5 et 6000
personnes déclaré positif par jour dont
ça à peine 24 heures on s'est réveillé à
40 5 me dont 48 heures à plus dé 58
personnes contaminées en espagne
merci beaucoup creuser dorado pour
toutes ces précisions sur la situation
en espagne joue je rappelle bien sûr que
vous êtes journaliste espagnol merci
beaucoup